avec causses nour sirène présidente de
raids actions média spécialiste de la
turquie
bonsoir madame merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous sur rt france face à vous il y
à jean marie bockel ancien sénateur et
ancien secrétaire d'état à la défense
sous la présidence de nicolas sarkozy
bonsoir merci d'être là pour débattre
sur rt france première question pour
vous au sourcil rennes
comment qualifieriez-vous les propos
tenus par le président turc à l'égard du
président emmanuel macron bonsoir tout
d'abord merci d'un mois va de m'avoir
permis de prendre la parole sur le sujet
de sa remontée important je suis
triplement concerné par tout ce qui se
passe entre la tuque à la france parce
que je suis à la fois turc musulman et
je vis en france et donc où commencer et
les propos du président elle doit on
peut bien évidemment les critiquer et ne
pas les cautionner
il faut aussi comprendre le lierre plein
de ces propos est premièrement vous
savez que les deux pays ont des
différends dans différents régions du
monde que ce soit en libye en syrie en
méditerranée orientale est actuellement
dans le haut karabakh aussi et les tout
ce qui se passe malheureusement d'après
le terrible attentat de sin-le-noble
samuel paty et l'ambiance de chaos et de
stigmatisation de musulmans en france et
qui règne dans le pays
malheureusement suscite la colère et
l'indignation de tous les musulmans du
monde donc l'egypte on y parle dont il a
réagi à la fois en tant que chef d'état
en tant qu' en tant que chef d'état qui
a toujours défendu les droits des
musulmans de prier dans le monde entier
que ce soit et les palestiniens les
ouïghours les rengaines en birmanie mais
aussi actuellement les musulmans en
europe mais aussi en tant que simples
musulmans et qui n'accepte pas et le
fait que emmanuel lafont de réformes et
structuré d'islam et confirmant de la
volonté des millions de musulmans voire
1,10 milliard de musulmans
super oui sauf qu'il veut réformer
l'islam de france et non pas l'islam
dans le
éd même question pour vous monsieur
bockel comment est ce que vous avez reçu
ces propos du président turc à l'égard
du président français je les ai reçus
ces propos absolument scandaleuse mot
est faible comme la confirmation de la
pertinence du discours du président
français et de la volonté française
à mon avis assez tardive de rappeler un
certain nombre de principes fondateurs
de notre pays je suis naturellement en
total désaccord avec ce que vient de
dire votre invité dans la mesure où elle
vient de procéder par un amalgame que
personnellement je trouve inadmissible
entre la situation des musulmans en
france dont beaucoup sont français pour
parfaitement leur place
enfin là on voit bien que à travers le
discours du président abdou gagnent même
ce que vous avez dit il ya une
instrumentalisation faire une
comparaison avec certaines minorités
persécutées dans certains pays
la nasa n'a aucun sens ça procède
vraiment d'une manipulation grossière et
moi je moi qui vous parle je suis un ami
de la turquie
j'ai été maire de la ville de mulhouse
pendant plus de vingt ans où il ya une
communauté très importante avec
d'ailleurs toutes les sensibilités de la
communauté turque que communauté avec
laquelle j'ai toujours entretenu les
meilleures relations
un jet au delà des turcs eux une
minorité musulmane extrêmement
importante avec laquelle j'ai toujours
été un dialogue un est d'ailleurs hui
eux mêmes sont les premiers à
reconnaître que 1 le terme
d'islamophobie qui est d'ailleurs
lui-même à terme je trouve assez
manipuler mais bon c'est un autre débat
ça n'a jamais été notre manière de
travailler
et moi qui suis donc un ami de la
turquie et qui d'ailleurs a été pendant
des années à ses objectifs sur les
positions du président et redonne il y
avait une réussite économique y avait un
dialogue y avait une présence
à l'otan où j'ai siégé pendant de
nombreuses années à l'assemblée
parlementaire de l'otan qui nous faisait
qui nous amener à faire la part des
choses entre une idéologie l'islam
politique est la sienne que nous ne
partageons pas mais une nécessité de
dialoguer avec un grand pays à pays avec
lequel nous avons des intérêts communs
dans l'est avec lequel nous mêmes
alliances mais là il ya depuis quelques
temps un un dérapage des excès de
langage des insultes
il ya eu aussi bien sur des
positionnements dans la méditerranée
avec derrière des enjeux à la fois
économiques et géopolitiques ça n'est
pas la bonne méthode
la bonne méthode c'est de dialogue et il
n'y a pas en france ça n'existe pas 1 1
comment dirais-je une une mise au pilori
des musulmans la plupart des musulmans
français sont bien en france sont
souvent français ont leur place sont
reconnus sont respectés ont leurs lieux
de culte mais il ya une dérive depuis
quelques années au smic terrible qui
d'ailleurs au niveau mondial relève un
petit peu de l'islam politique est une
forme de fondamentalistes et de
fondamentalisme et celle là ne pouvons
pas l'accepter
ou alors la france ne sera plus la
france osnoss irréel
d'ailleurs cette colère du président r
douane est la preuve que nous avons
appuyé là où ça fait mal et ça n'est pas
que le prise d'un maquereau c'est
l'ensemble des responsables français qui
considèrent que ça ne peut pas continuer
comme ça haussler sirène est ce que
vraiment cette question d'avoir offensé
les musulmans finalement et et la bonne
analyse on sait que le président r doan
vous étendre son leadership dans le
monde son influence
après tout c'est aussi une de ses
ambitions le fait par exemple de
s'immiscer dans le conflit du
nagorny-karabakh la turquie n'était pas
historiquement partie prenante en tout
cas dans cette région du monde donc est
ce qu'il ya vraiment une velléité en
tout cas de vouloir asseoir son
impérialisme
non bien évidemment il n'y a pas de
volonté d'imposer son impérialisme tout
d'abord en fait j'aimerais bien de cela
mercier à monsieur local fo 100%
témoignages il dit qu' il prend le
dialogue et l'apaisement dans les deux
pays et moi je suis tout à fait d'accord
là dessus et bien évidemment je ne
cautionne pas du tout une escalade
verbale entre les deux pays et toutes
ces tensions
et moi je voudrais bien souligné que ces
deux pays sont des alliés au sein de
l'otan
et ils ont de très bonnes relations
économiques et bien évidemment on
aimerait bien que tout cela ne m'arrive
jamais c'est ça que moi personnellement
je veux mais aussi laissé sans me
turquie qui résident en france mais
aussi tous les trucs qui sont en turquie
donc bien évidemment et il faut vraiment
que ce soit clair que moi je consomme
absolument pas tout ce qui se passe et
comme escalade verbale et tensions entre
les deux pays et nous nous voulons le
dialogue et en dehors de ça et pour
revenir dans le question du haut
karabakh et nous pensons quand même que
le français en faisant partie est du
groupe de minsk qui qui est là pour les
autres un conflit qui dure depuis 30 ans
elle n'est pas neutre elle devrait
garder son ex rihanna n'est pas neutre à
la fois le président maintenant mais
aussi des élus politiques
ils ont une position en faveur de
l'harmonie et nous pensons que dans sa
la diaspora arménienne de france joue un
rôle important
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est quand
même acceptable et c'est normal que la
france et tranches vraiment nos
positions en faveur de l'arménie alors
que justement elle doit encourager et le
cessez le feu entre les deux pays et
garder sa neutralité en faisant partie
du groupe de minsk c'est la première
question est deuxième et chose que je
voudrais souligner c'est que la turquie
a toujours eu des relations historiques
culturels et très proche avec
l'azerbaïdjan qui est canadien pourtant
de la turquie et donc du coup c'est tout
à fait normal aussi que la turquie
apporte son soutien
à ce pays dont 20% des territoires sont
occupés illégalement par les forces
armées liens et donc du coup la turquie
un coulage la résolution de ce conflit
avec le retrait des forces armées n'a ni
dégâts question à vous gens n'arrivent
auquel on l'a dit la turquie fait partie
de l'otan évidemment c'est un allié il y
a des escalades verbales avec la france
mais pas avec les autres pays membres de
l'otan et il y a quand même cette
question qui se pose de plus en plus est
ce que la turquie a toujours sa place au
sein de l'otan avec cette attitude qui
montre en tout cas le contraire je vais
vous répondre je voudrais simplement
d'une phrase j'ai écouté avec beaucoup
d'attention les propos de vos propos
madame concernant le conflit du haut
karabagh je fais partie des français qui
connaissent les deux pays qui savent
qu'il y a une influence de cette
diaspora de ce point de vue là vous avez
raison de dire mais en même temps c'est
ancré dans une histoire une histoire et
des tragiques mais je fais aussi partie
de ces français grâce un peu
l'azerbaïdjan et qui sont aussi des amis
de l'azerbaïdjan et donc je fais partie
de ceux qui pensent aujourd'hui encore
que la france au sein du groupe de minsk
avec la russie particulièrement mais
aussi les etats-unis et les pays
concernés peut jouer un rôle
et la france n'a pas pris parti la
france n'a pas pu et partie je veux
parler un des autorités françaises le
chef de l'état 1 nous restons sur une
position non pas de neutralité 1 mais
d'engagement pour le dialogue et pour le
retour et une situation à la fois de
paix de cessez-le-feu mais également une
situation qui permette de résoudre ce
conflit vieux de bientôt trois décennies
alors je vais juste répondant même si
rennes excusez moi monsieur vocal epyon
on ira sur cette question le temps juste
après répondait madame sirène vous
n'êtes pas d'accord et oui quand vous le
gardez la position des élus français et
vous voyez comment qu'il ya eu prise de
parti en faveur de l'arménie par exemple
est-ce que
on est en plein lutte le gouvernement
annonce qu'il a en plein lutte contre le
communautarisme mais on voit quand même
à côté une députée qu'on voyait les bois
hier et qui défendent les thésards
méliane en plis en assemblée nationale
et de l'autre côté au gouvernement c'est
pas la position officielle du
gouvernement valérie boyer et madame
sirène gestion nous devons tous nous
serons d'accord faire la part des choses
entre un certain nombre d'élus qui sont
engagés pour des raisons effectivement
de présence d'une communauté importante
arménienne aussi parce que c'est leur
conviction et c'est évidemment des
convictions que je respecte mais il y à
la position de l'état français inquiets
eux est un état qui a des relations avec
l'azerbaïdjan également ainsi qu avec
l'arménie en général lorsque les chefs
d'état se rendent dans la région ils
vont dans les deux pays font bien
attention à préserver cet équilibre
donc effectivement il ne faut pas
mélanger les choses concernant la
question doit déposer tout à l'heure et
je vous prie de m'excuser de ne pas y
avoir répondu tout de suite mais c'était
bien qu'on s'arrête quelques instants
sur cette actualité brûlante du haut
karabakh
oui sur le temps est ce que la turquie
en consumant franchement j'ai parfois
l'impression car il y à la fois l'otan
et la position européenne
j'ai parfois l'impression que la france
sur des enjeux extrêmement sensible sera
plan géopolitique peut-être parce que
nous sommes membres permanents du
conseil de sécurité des nations unies la
france et est un petit peu poussé en
première ligne 1 est là c'est aussi le
cas bien sûr derrière ou et bien le
boycott
les actions de boycott qui sont lancés
contre des intérêts français montrent
que de prises de position ne sont pas
neutres
moi je pense qu'on gagnerait à être
davantage unis au niveau européen car
certains pays qui sont peut-être un
petit peu prudent ambigu un peu inquiet
1 parce qu'il se laisse un peu
impressionnés par les colères du
président ardoines devrait y réfléchir à
deux fois parce que mon histoire nous
montre chaque fois qu'on cède chaque
fois qu'on se dit oulala attendons ça se
passe ne lui répondant pas et c'est à la
fin ça se termine toujours mal
donc autant être uni fort et déterminé
tant qu'on est encore dans
l'appréhension d'une dégradation qui
pourrait être plus grave parce que
prisonnière doan il n'est pas à lui seul
tout lâcher toute la turquie on le sait
bien ce papier que je connais bien où
j'ai beaucoup d'amis je sais qu'il ya
beaucoup de turcs eux de toute
sensibilité de toute région qui
souhaitent que la relation s'améliore
donc là il ya une dimension politique à
l'otan ou encore une fois moi j'ai très
très bien travaillé dans dans
l'assemblée parlementaire avec mes
collègues turcs eux donc je les connais
bien et moi je souhaite que cette
alliance piscines
est ce que cette alliance puisse se
poursuivre parce que si demain cette
alliance s'arrêtait évidemment ce serait
pousser la turquie vers d'autres
alliances de tête irait dans le sens des
pensions actuels du président r douanes
qui essaie de fédérer sort d'islam
politique un dans cette partie du monde
ce serait extrêmement inquiète al
si la question est est ce que ça peut
continuer comme ça ma réponse est non
ça ne peut pas continuer comme ça on va
laisser passer la présidence américaine
parce que d'ici là il va rien se passer
mais après il faudra tout de même que
avec l'ensemble des alliés de l'otan à
commencer par les etats-unis mais aussi
les pays européens eh bien on met à plat
une une position forte avec des
conditions claires vis-à-vis de nature
guide parce que vous savez des
personnalités politiques telles que le
président r doan s'il en croit la
manière dont il s'exprime en ce moment
eh bien on a le sentiment que ils
comprennent d'abord le rapport de force
il faut que nous ayons tente au niveau
européen qu'au niveau des partenaires de
l'otan un rapport de force claire parce
que si nous sommes divisés parce que si
nous sommes faibles
nous allons l'encouragé dans ses dérives
au jour une sirène je ne suis pas
toujours
j'en arrive auquel vous parlez beaucoup
je voudrais aussi laissé la parole à
madame sirène pardon madame sirène même
question 1 est-ce que selon vous
en tout cas au vu des volontés en tout
cas d'indépendance du chef de l'état
turc par rapport à ses engagements dans
l'otan est ce qu'il ya une volonté de
s'en éloigner
non il n'y a pas de volonté de
s'éloigner ou de sortir de l'otan on ne
peut pas dire ça mais la turquie a
toujours cette impression qui n'est pas
comprise a cessé ses préoccupations de
légitimes ne sont pas prises en
considération par ses partenaires
européens et la france
malheureusement dans beaucoup de pays
que ce soit en syrie en libye et
maintenant de dans les régions de la
méditerranée orientale dans le haut
karabakh ne comprend pas ne veut pas
comprendre ne veut pas écouter les
thèses de la turquie depuis un certain
temps la turquie assume tout seuls le
fardeau des migrantes en syrie et dans
le pays
elle mène une lutte contre le terrorisme
sans relâche sans que qu'elle soit
réellement soutenu par ses partenaires
européens et donc ces conflits ces
tensions entre la turquie et les pays de
l'union européenne s'accumulent et il ya
vraiment un problème de communication
il faut vraiment que toutes les parties
prend le temps d'écouter leur thèse les
arguments pour trouver un compromis
on ne peut pas toujours montré le bâton
et dire à la turquie vit il y aurait des
sanctions en ville y aura des et des à
la fin on va imposer des embargos quoi
que ce soit des il y aura des problèmes
économiques c'est pas comme ça que ça
marche c'est le rapport de force ne mène
à rien vous voyez bien que en
méditerranée orientale de la turquie
continue poursuit ses activités de
recherche sismique avec son avis rorys
qu'elle donc du coup toutes les toutous
ce rapport de force là bas n'ont abouti
à rien donc du coup et au bout d'un
moment il faut que tout le monde se met
à table il faut que tout le monde dise
ce qu'elle attend ce qu'il attend de
l'autre et c'est juste dans une ambiance
que de 2,2 dialogue constructif qu'on
pourra avancer et actuellement pour
devenir en fait à tout ce qui se passe
en lien avec l'islam et la france tout
intérêt à s'allier avec un pays comme la
turquie et qui contiennent qui abrite
environ 80 millions de musulmans
aussi qu'ils aient vu actuellement par
le monde musulman comme le leader du
monde musulman donc et la france n'a pas
du tout intérêt à apprendre la turquie
comme adversaire ou comme comme ennemi
rien j'en arrive auquel dernière
question très court s'il vous plaît est
ce que c'est pas emmanuel macron qui a
aussi tendance à attiser les braises
on a vu qu'ils n'étaient pas suivies
notamment sa réunion européenne excusez
moi il faut qu allons revenir aux
raisons pour laquelle on est seul aux
raisons pour lesquelles on est sur votre
plateau c'est quand même le président
johan 1 qui a traité le président macron
de ballades mentale au bout ça quand
même
on va ça fait donc non mais attendez
même pas vu je parle pas du président
poutine qui est quelqu'un de bien élever
et de police mais ça quand même
on attend si vous voulez à un niveau d'
insulte 1
je n'ai jamais entendu le président de
macron traité qui que ce soit de cette
manière donc la jumellière madame ce que
vous avez dit sur le dialogue sur la
nécessité de se mettre autour de la
table
je ne peux être que d'accord avec vous
il ya quand même un moment donné ou trop
c'est trop
c'est donc inacceptable et aujourd'hui
excusez moi et aujourd'hui
évidemment le temps n'est pas à l'escala
parce que nous sommes en france des gens
responsables et nous avons également un
vrai dialogue avec nos alliés mais le
temps est venu dire maintenant ça suffit
et concernant la question du leadership
de l'islam ça je vous laisse la
responsabilité de vos propos que
monsieur r2 que monsieur erdogan veut y
être exercé un leadership politique sur
l'islam
ça c'est peut-être possible mais nous
nous n'avons pas à me soumettre à ce
plan politique nous n'avons pas à
rentrer dans ce type de débat ne nous
avons à trouver dans d'autres pays avec
notre tradition avec notre respect des
religions avec notre respect également
de la liberté d'expression et de laïcité
notre propre mode de fonctionnement
merci croyez-moi nous menacent et faire
des boycotts nous insulter ça n'est pas
la bonne méthode au contraire ça nous
conforte dans l'idée qu'il était temps
qu'on prenne un certain nombre de
mesures et croyez moi la plupart des
musulmans français ont tout à fait
conscience eux mêmes qui sont les
premières victimes
un de ces dérives de l'islam politique
et fondamentalistes 6 3 merci beaucoup
on a largement dépassé le temps
appartient ce débat très court madame
sirène juste deux mots s'il vous plaît
et on est on est on arrête ce débat
oui j'ai pas dit que monsieur al douane
il veut insérer les saints politique ou
quoi que ce soit j'ai dit que dans le
monde les peuples musulmans voient la
turquie actuellement adjoint plutôt
comme le leader du monde musulman donc
du coup ça peut être vraiment le message
très fort c'est la france alliée avec
est un pays comme la turquie
ça c'est la première chose que je dirai
ensuite au niveau 2 c'était juste la
réponse à ce qu'avait dit monsieur
bockel malheureusement on n'a pas le
temps de développer vos propos merci en
tout cas à tous les deux d'avoir
participé à ce débat sur rt france un
débat que l'on reprendra bien sûr
j'imagine dans les jours prochains